JOANNA SMITH: Screen real estate
on devices is pretty scarce,
and material design
encourages apps to have
a simpler and cleaner look.
But this can make it
difficult for users
to discover all of the
options your app offers.
I'm Joanna Smith, and this
is exactly why you should
consider a navigation drawer.
A navigation drawer
is a panel of options
on the left edge of the screen.
Usually, it is hidden from view.
But it can be revealed when
the user swipes from the left.
It may also be
permanently visible
if there's enough screen
real estate, such as a tablet
in landscape mode.
Having a navigation
drawer, commonly
referred to as the left
nav, allows your app
to offer a wealth of
features and behaviors,
without being
visually overwhelming.
So you get to keep your most
important features front
and center, and then when
the user is looking for more,
they can open this menu.
By now, you're completely
convinced that you need
to build a left nav right away.
So allow me to show
you what to do.
First, you're going to
create a drawer layout.
The drawer layout
should be the root view
and contain two child views.
The first child must be the
view from the main content
of the screen.
This is for when your
left nav is hidden,
so that when the drawer is
later opened, it will be on top.
The second child is the view for
the navigation drawer itself.
After you've got
your layout, you'll
need the list of items
that will fill it.
A navigation view makes
this easy by providing
the framework you need
for the navigation drawer.
You just need to provide
the navigation view widget
with two things-- the header
layout, if you have one,
and the menu of list items.
The menu is actually
pretty great
since it allows you to inflate
your content from a menu XML
resource instead of managing
a list view programmatically.
And even better,
this means that you
get all of your
material design styling
on the nav drawer for free.
This mini resource
can be as simple
as a collection of
checkable menu items.
Whichever is currently
checked will be displayed
as the highlighted nav item.
However, you can also
build more complex menus
by using sub-headers to
group items together.
Now that you have your
list of navigation items,
you'll need to respond
to click events.
You'll get callbacks
on selected items
by setting an on navigation
item selected listener
using set navigation
item selected listener.
This callback provides you with
the menu item that was clicked,
allowing you to handle
selection events,
change the check status,
load new content, and so on.
Now if your navigation
drawer is not
a permanent view in your
app, which is highly likely,
you'll want to listen for
open and close events.
This will allow you to
make any adjustments you
need before switching views.
The default checker for
opening the navigation drawer
is a swipe from the left.
But you can also use
the hamburger icon
to toggle the drawer
open and closed.
Now there's one final note.
I've been referring to
the navigation drawer
as a left nav, but
that does not mean
it must always be on the left.
If your app supports right
to left layouts, for example,
and you've already marked your
layouts with start and end
attributes instead of
left and right ones,
the system will create a
right nav for you instead.
This way, your RTL users
can swipe from the right
to open the navigation
drawer, and it
will be properly aligned on
the right side of the screen.
So to learn more about Android
dev and to make sure that
your app is at its best, check
out the rest of our Android
Development Patterns content,
and consider joining the G+
community for tips,
tricks, and help.
But most importantly, just
continue to build better apps.